let's talk a little bit about Donald
Trump's personal finances for a moment
so we've got the Trump Russia
investigation that is going on and sort
of the catalyst for that investigation
is was there
collusion which could include a number
of different possible crimes between a
non friendly foreign power namely Russia
and the Donald Trump administration that
was the initial catalyst for Robert
molars special prosecutor investigation
that that is ongoing right now but there
are a couple of other directions that
the investigation could go and arguably
has started to go one is well are their
crimes in terms of the cover-up around
possible collusion that is we hear that
all the time right it's not the crime
it's the cover-up that's one direction
the other possible direction that the
Robert Moeller investigation could go in
is a focus on financial crimes and we
had a sense that that might be going on
because for some time now robert muller
has been hiring a number of prosecutors
who are experts in prosecuting financial
crimes investigating financial crimes so
there was already a sense that that's a
direction that it could be going now I
want to remind you that Donald Trump was
asked about well what if Robert Muller
starts going in the direction of looking
into your personal finances and before I
tell you what's happening now because
hint it's happening I want to remind you
that when Donald Trump was interviewed
by the New York Times back in July of
this year he was asked if that were to
happen if Robert Muller started looking
into you and your family's personal
finances would that cross a sort of red
line and Donald Trump said that it would
and here's the transcript from that
interview with the New York Times where
Donald Trump was sitting in this
interview and one of the journalists
Schmidt said last thing if Muller was
looking at your finances and your family
finance is unrelated to Russia is that a
red line and Maggie Haberman added would
that be a breach of what his actual
charges and Donald Trump said pretty
clearly I would say yeah I would say yes
by the way I would say I don't I mean
it's possible there's a condo or
something so you know I sell a lot of
condo units and somebody from Russia
buys a condo who knows I don't make
money from Russia
going on but the point there is that
Trump said yes if Robert Muller did
start looking into my family's finances
it would cross a proverbial red line
well it's happening Donald Trump's
personal banking information is now in
the hands of special prosecutor Robert
Muller this continues to suggest that
this is increasingly a financial crimes
investigation Donald Trump's biggest
lender for his business as of late
anyway has been deutsche bank a german
bank and they've now been forced to turn
over documents about their relationship
with Donald Trump after being subpoenaed
by Robert Muller's investigation now the
right is going to downplay this but this
is huge in either of two scenarios this
could mean one of two different things
and both of them mean a lot scenario one
is that the Deutsche Bank documents are
related to Russia stuff specifically
that would be big in and of itself
because it would mean hey that Russian
interactions are wide reaching enough to
involve German banks so if this is
related directly to Russia specifically
that would be news in and of itself but
think about the other side if the
Deutsche Bank stuff has nothing to do
with Russia specifically that's also
huge because it would confirm that
indeed Donald Trump's personal finances
are a growing area of concern for the
Moller team we've already had four
indictments and if at this time
Robert Moeller continues to subpoena
financial documents that don't have to
do with Russia
that tells us that there is a lot here
that is not even directly related to
Russia and of course it is fully within
Robert Moeller's purview to investigate
any possible crimes that his team learns
about the possibility of through their
initial investigation that's how these
special prosecutors work now what will
Donald Trump do well again Trump said if
Muller does this it would be crossing a
red line I would say yeah is what Donald
Trump said I hope that Donald Trump is
reinvigorated in his thought about
firing Robert Moeller because that would
be absolutely monumental at this point
and very interesting that it's not been
a good 24 to 36 hours for Donald Trump
and after tweeting yesterday
morning Monday morning Trump has been
silent on Twitter constant news breaking
over the last 24 hours and at least as
of 15 minutes ago when I looked at
Donald Trump's Twitter account we heard
nothing from him which is not really
like Trump and to me suggests the guy is
clearly worried I mean maybe he is
learning his lesson but maybe he also
will find this as justification to fire
Robert Muller may be looking at my
personal finances I don't like this it's
starting to seem almost like the
President himself might be under
investigation oh wait a second we knew
that we knew that although Trump and his
cronies have been trying to deny that
Trump is personally under investigation
it's clear that Trump is personally
under investigation period and then then
what's what's going to be the next
defense Donald Trump had a very minor
role in the campaign and in the
administration he was just a figurehead
he wasn't really responsible for
anything it was actually Jared Kushner
who was really out running things in
Steve ban and when he was around he knew
nothing and he was kept out of the loop
it is becoming more and more difficult
to separate right now and I know Alex
Omaha sure yesterday said he doesn't
believe that Pence is separate from any
of this stuff because if he was the one
being lied to by Flynn clearly the
series of events that just Pence was
involved I I don't know that I agree
with Alex I think Pence is increasingly
the only one where there's any plausible
deniability about what he knew I mean I
don't think there is any evidence and
there really isn't too much speculation
about Mike Pence either not that many
people talking here at this point
at this point I think is the key thing
and I I would actually add a caveat to
that I would say from the point of view
of what's known in the public record it
appears as though Mike Pence's name is
clear as of right now but my suspicion
is that Mike Pence actually does know
more than than what's being discussed
and that is ultimately what the future
of the United States presidency could
hinge on right because if this continues
to grow and eventually we have I don't
know impeachment resignation who knows
what one of the key questions is going
to become do we all just accept that
Mike Pence was in no way involved and he
becomes clean and clear the next
president of the United States or do we
look at pence being implicated in this
as well right from but
from a policy perspective I don't know
that it matters that much no I don't
think so Mike Pence and Paul Ryan the
Speaker of the House who wanted to sign
the president in that case come from the
same cloth very similar I don't know if
you would agree I think Paul Ryan is a
little bit less of an ideological
religious extremist than Mike Pence but
certainly when it comes to fiscal stuff
absolutely cut from the same cloth send
me your thoughts that's the latest that
we've learned I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show today's program is sponsored in
part by live lingua here's the bottom
line your relatives and friends don't
need any more fancy kitchen tools that
they'll never use or things that are
just gonna sit in a cabinet right if
you're looking for a gift that your
friends and family will love consider
the gift of language immersive language
lessons with live lingua are a great way
to give a memorable and meaningful
holiday gift this year give cards
available at live linguae dot-com slash
Pakman I will warn you that live lingua
does not offer some trendy new gimmick
where they'll make you fluent in a new
language after a month of five minutes a
day of practice right their method is a
proven approach to creating fluency and
confidence in one of 11 of the most
widely spoken languages in the world
they are immersive language learning
with actual native speakers of the
languages designed to give you comfort
in the new language you'll work
one-on-one with your teacher via Skype
no worry of falling behind the rest of
the class and no needing to schlep
around in traffic getting to your
teacher to your teachers location for
the class and this holiday season our
listeners our viewers of the David
Pakman show have a sort of one-up on
gift giving the best part of all of this
is that not only can you get 20% off
gift cards you will also get the first
lesson absolutely free you can go to
live lingua kaam slash Pakman learn more
pick up a gift card and by the way
nobody will say anything if you use the
20% discounted gift card for yourself
check it out live lengua comm slash
Pakman